on december 25th 1991 mikhail gorbachev
resigned as general secretary of the
communist party and is president of the
soviet union
a half hour later the red flag over the
kremlin emblazoned with hammer and
sickle was lowered the soviet union was
no more
there had been no mass protests on the
streets of moscow no military conflict
with a foreign or domestic enemy
and yet the unthinkable had just
occurred
the individual republics comprising the
union of soviet socialist republics had
declared their independence
and one of history's largest empires
disintegrated into the darkness of the
winter evening
what had happened since gorbachev came
to power just six years earlier
princeton university historian stephen
cotkin offers us a clue
he says that gorbachev tried to make the
communist party both the instrument and
the object of his reforms
and this proved untenable
gorbachev was a devout communist
believer an idealistic reformer who was
among the most accidental
revolutionaries in history
he'd wanted to reform communism in order
to save it
and yet he unintentionally dismantled
the soviet union in the process
in many ways gorbachev's idealism was
sandwiched between the authoritarian
tendencies that both proceeded and
followed him
the neo-stalinism of his most
significant contemporary predecessor
leonard brezhnev
and the neo czarist era of his most
significant successor vladimir putin
but to understand this we need to go
back
in history to a time when leonid
brezhnev pushed his one-time patron
nikita khushov from power and in 1964
party coup
leonid brezhnev had been just a boy when
vladimir lenin led the bolshevik
revolution that initiated the soviet
period in 1917.
brezhnev became a full member of the
communist party in his twenties and for
a time he worked as an engineer
until devoting himself to politics
his standing in party circles rose
thanks to the support of khushov after
joseph stalin's death in 1953
brezhnev repaid khrushchev by supporting
his benefactor when the so-called
anti-party group tried to push
khrushchev from office in 1957
but the next time it would be brezhnev
who led the coup
the brezhnev years in the soviet union
from 1964 to 1982 are usually described
as a period of stagnation
but it was one of the most stable eras
in ussr history
more soviet citizens than ever before
enjoyed better access to household items
like refrigerators telephones and
televisions
and the number of people living in
communal apartments dropped
the problem was that soviet citizens
expectations had also grown
khrushchev had vowed that the soviet
union would overtake the united states
economically by 1970.
but brezhnev inherited a declining
economy
and throughout his tenure the growth
rate trudged along at roughly one
percent a year
a large military budget and the high
cost associated with maintaining soviet
hegemony in eastern europe
put a damper on the aging revolution
at the same time corruption and
patronage benefited some actors in the
state economy at the expense of others
and the black market flourished like
never before
one growth area during the version of
years a period known as advanced
socialism was in alcohol consumption
people drank out of desperation
and alcoholism became a national scourge
the soviet people didn't always know the
details of their country's economic
problems but they felt them
you see
empty store shelves belied the positive
assessments appearing in soviet
newspapers like pravda meaning truth and
izvestia translated as news
this gave rise to the soviet joke that
there was no truth in pravda and no news
in his viestia
the vast majority of soviet citizens
weren't dissidents
but they weren't naive stooges of the
communist government either
and so
one way that everyday soviets gave voice
to the absurdity of the situation was
through jokes
called anecdotes in the russian language
alexei yurchak a professor of
anthropology at uc berkeley defines
anecdoti as
short formulaic jokes that constituted a
popular genre of irony during the
brezhnev years
these witticisms poked fun at soviet
leaders at the soviet system
and at people's complicity in keeping
socialism afloat
one joke refers to brezhnev driving his
elderly mother to moscow for a visit
looking around her son's luxurious
apartment filled with persian rugs
imported vases and antique furniture she
asked with alarm
what will happen to you if the
communists come back
my favorite though is the one about a
man on moscow's red square shouting
brezhnev is an idiot
immediately he is seized by security
forces and sentenced to 15 years
five years for insulting the soviet
leader and 10 years for betraying a
state secret
the soviets might laugh at their leaders
but they still found cause for pride in
their nation
particularly every four years when the
olympic games got underway
the soviet state had always emphasized
the importance of physical fitness for
its people
during the cold war olympian
competitions between western and soviet
black athletes achieved importance on
par with state diplomacy
the soviet hockey team suffered an
unlikely setback at the hands of amateur
american ice hockey players at the 1980
winter games in lake placid new york
but once it did the soviets plotted
their redemption at the 1980 summer
games to be held in moscow
unfortunately for fort sports fans the
soviet invasion of afghanistan in late
1979
resulted in a boycott of the moscow
olympics by 66 countries including the
united states
the soviets intervened to prop up a
leftist regime in afghanistan and this
dragged on for a decade at a cost of 15
000 soviet lives and a tremendous amount
of money
bershnev never saw fit to disengage
he and his fellow aging members of the
polyp bureau ruled complacently
even as the economic growth rate fell to
zero
william and mary historian stephen
hansen says
five decades after the bolshevik
revolution the revolutionary dream of
transforming the nature of modernity
itself
was increasingly giving way
to complacency among the older
generation
of which brezhnev and the polyp bureau
were apart
after all the ruling elite continued to
enrich themselves at the expense of the
nation
even brezhnev's daughter galena got in
on the act
allegedly smuggling diamonds out of the
country by hiding them in circus animals
it seems incredible
but this was the soviet reality
the system had moved away from the
bolsheviks utopian visions of the 1920s
and there seemed to be no prospects for
change
then
the leadership started to die
and unlike at other times in soviet
history these deaths weren't nefarious
instead soviet leaders were dying from
old age
in the early 1980s the deaths of
high-ranking soviet or party officials
became commonplace
including the 75-year-old brezhnev
himself
but instead of replacing the late
brezhnev with someone from a younger
generation
the politburo named the 70 year old yuri
and dropoff as the new general secretary
and he died 14 months later
in february 1984.
next up was the 74 year old constantine
chernienko who lasted barely a year
before expiring in march of 1985.
alexey yerchak the uc berkeley historian
with a well-deserved developed sense of
humor
relates a soviet joke from the time that
captures just how ridiculous the
situation was becoming
it goes as follows
a man is approaching red square while
the funeral of yet another politburo
member is underway
he's stopped by a state security officer
who asks him if he has a pass to the
great man's funeral
a pass the soviet citizen replies i have
a season ticket
it was after cernenko's death that the
party leadership named the 52 year old
mikhail gorbachev as the next general
secretary of the communist party and
leader of the country
having come of age during the cultural
thaw of the kuchal vera in the 1950s and
early 1960s
it's clear that this experience had
stayed with gorbachev
and now mikhail initiated a platform of
reform
ostensibly to save the revolution
unfortunately for him
the high global oil prices of the 1970s
that had allowed for a measure of
economic stability in the soviet union
had since gone bust
furthermore the ussr faced a stagnant
economy
the ruinous war in afghanistan
and a surge of military spending by the
united states under its anti-communist
president ronald reagan
seeing the necessity
gorbachev initiated a restructuring of
the soviet centrally planned economy
known as perestroika
it called for a more flexible system of
economic management and opportunities
for enterprises to become self-financing
however for the new plan to succeed
gorbachev believed that soviet citizens
also needed to be more informed
this initiated his policy of glasnost
glasnost removed the rigid limitations
of state censorship and allowed for
unprecedented levels of freedom of
expression
gorbachev hoped that glasnost would
rejuvenate the soviet people
instead
it exposed systemic social and political
problems
and these irrevocably tarnished many of
the legitimizing myths of the soviet
system
on the television nightly news soviets
began to see social upheavals once
hidden from sight
one exception was the horrific accident
at the chernobyl nuclear power station
in northern ukraine in april 1986.
the gorbachev government issued no
statement on the accident for days
instead clinging to decades-old habits
of maintaining silence in the face of
domestic disasters
as the chernobyl ash swept across
northern europe
radiation detectors in sweden
measured pronounced levels of
radioactivity
only then
did the soviet government begin to tell
the people and the world the truth
dozens of people were dead
and tens of thousands more had been
exposed to disastrous levels of
radiation
this turned into a public relations
nightmare for the gorbachev regime
and by the time the soviet leader
delivered a television address about the
disaster three weeks later
he'd squandered much of his credibility
public confidence was undermined
other forces also conspired against the
new soviet leader including some that he
had unleashed
underground books and music reflecting
the thoughts of the soviet union's
gifted dissidents now had official press
runs and pressings
and they lined store shelves
in turn the economic restructuring
perestroika
necessitated new sources of state
funding
gorbachev decided that the most
expedient source of savings was in
military expenditures
so
he worked to find a way out of
afghanistan
to reduce the arms race with the
americans
and to extricate the soviets from their
commitments in eastern europe
in a 1988 speech before the united
nations general assembly in new york
city
gorbachev renounced the so-called
brezhnev doctrine
under the brezhnev doctrine the soviet
union had reserved the right to
intervene in any state where socialism
was in jeopardy
it had first been used to crush the
prague spring of czechoslovakia in 1968
but now
gorbachev rejected the very framework
that had helped maintain soviet hegemony
in eastern europe since the end of world
war ii and throughout the cold war
he also announced that the ussr would
reduce the forces in eastern europe by
500 000 over the next two years
this proved
decisive without moscow's military
support the communist regimes of eastern
europe fell in quick succession
and in the soviet union
protesters filled red square
on may day
1990 with jeers boos and calls to resign
as gorbachev and his fellow leaders
stood by glumly
meanwhile gorbachev had also created a
new legislature called the congress of
people's deputies that had introduced
contested elections and a new crop of
politicians on the national stage
these included the former de facto mayor
of moscow boris yeltsin
yeltsin had suffered mixed political
fortunes under gorbachev including a
significant demotion in the communist
party in 1988 and allegations of public
drunkenness the following year
but he was elected to the congress of
people's deputies in march 1989.
and now he led a radical reform faction
gorbachev's position worsened after he
supported an initiative to end the
communist party's monopoly on power in
february 1990.
this was an attempt to gain control of
the reforming tide that was surging past
him
a month later he was elected to the
newly created position of president of
the soviet union
and appeared to have weathered the storm
but appearances were deceiving
the baltic republics of latvia lithuania
and estonia soon asserted their national
sovereignty
a threat more severe and immediate than
the dissolution of the eastern black had
been
boris yeltsin brilliantly used
nationalist sentiment to stake a claim
to authority apart from gorbachev
his popular rhetoric gave the soviets an
alternative in which to believe
as additional republics began to pull
away from moscow's control
gorbachev tried to salvage the union by
accommodating popular sentiment
he increasingly liberalized his policies
to stave off threats both from hardline
communists and nationalists like yeltsin
but in may 1990 two months after
gorbachev had been named president of
the soviet union
yeltsin was elected president of the
russian republic
the state's largest political entity
and if the two men had ever been allies
they weren't any longer
yeltsin cleverly championed the primacy
of the russian republic over the
authority of the soviet union
once he did other republics followed
suit
gorbachev was under pressure from other
factions as well
communist hardliners placed him under
house arrest in august 1991
and transferred power to the vice
president
but the plotters had failed to arrest
yeltsin
and as news spread that gorbachev was
being held
yeltsin made his way to the white house
the building that housed the russian
parliament
to organize a popular defense against
the coup
images of yeltsin standing on top of a
tank and rallying support for popular
visions of democracy were beamed
throughout the country and around the
world
within three days the pooch had failed
the counter-revolution
was over
in the immediate aftermath the soviet
congress of people's deputies was
disbanded as was the communist party
an individual soviet republics declared
their independence from the ussr
one after the other
so there was no longer any soviet union
left for gorbachev to lead
on december 25th 1991 he resigned
the era of the ussr had come to an end
when the soviet flag was lowered for the
last time from the top of the kremlin
and the tri-color flag of the russian
federation was raised in its place
no jubilant crowd stood shouting hurrah
however
no statues were ripped from their bases
no figure was burned in effigy
no group of revolutionaries embraced the
seemingly impossible as having been
accomplished
instead
newspaper reports described a sense of
uncertainty
as a small group of onlookers watched
this historic moment unfold
some
felt more than a little regret
one young woman told a reporter for the
new york times
i'm sorry for the soviet union
i'm sad
i'm sorry a great country is falling
apart before my eyes
as we now know the transition from
communism in the culture of a one-party
state to capitalism and democracy would
be exponentially more difficult than
exchanging one flag for another
communist apparatchiks didn't suddenly
become liberal democrats
they had a vested interest in
maintaining their prerogatives of power
and influence many had exploited the
system and even pilfered from the state
for years
decades of economic atrophy corruption
bribery secrecy and privileged access
also lingered
so when communism in the soviet state
fell
many former elites became the new
oligarchs
they
built their fortunes on the ruins of the
soviet economy and then used their
wealth to obtain political power
according to expatriate journalist masha
gessen
more troubles lay ahead
boris yeltsin's demeanor as a man of the
people who rode a bus to work soon
seemed a charade
his virtue receded behind a drunken haze
in both private and public
and he fell prey to cronyism corruption
and his own thirst for power
once a defender of russian democracy
having stood atop that tank before the
white house two years earlier
in 1993 yeltsin directed tanks to fire
on the russian parliament
in doing so he set the sa stage for a
new round of authoritarian rule
that would rival that of the romanov
czars and soviet commissars
russian parliamentarians drafted
constitutional amendments that would
limit yeltsin's power
but he used force to maintain control
he also expressed a communist leader's
typical unfamiliarity with capitalism
although yeltsin embraced economic
reforms as a sort of shock therapy to
transition to a market economy
these led to horrible inflation and
probations for the people
about the only russians who saw their
material fortunes improve
as the 1990s progressed were the new
oligarchs
yeltsin and his allies gave away soviet
state companies at bargain prices to
former communist era insiders the price
their political loyalty
yeltsin's health deteriorated as the
decade wore on
and his approval ratings fell
to less than 10 percent by the end of
the decade
still with the rampant corruption he
oversaw
those in ruling circles had an incentive
to make sure
that the next russian president wouldn't
throw the lot of them in jail
so in the late summer of 1999 they
plucked from obscurity a former kgb
official vladimir putin who appears to
have been the choice of several
oligarchs closely connected the yeltsin
a few months later yeltsin himself
resigned in a surprising new year's eve
address to the nation
and putin became president
in turn
putin made himself into the
non-yeltsin
he used separatist violence that rattled
the caucuses as an excuse to increase a
broader regional tendency towards
authoritarian rule
for instance a series of apartment
bombings in 1999 when he was still
yeltsin's prime minister
allowed putin to employ strong-armed
tactics and renew the bombing of the
chechen capital of grozny
after becoming president he took an
increasingly tough stance on the war in
chechnya
his demeanor as a tough no-nonsense
ruler who promised stability and safety
to a country buffeted by a decade of
turbulence and declining declining
global prestige
appealed to the population
meanwhile as the economy recovered from
its 1998 nader
putin's popularity grew in the years to
come he would engineer a level of
popularity rivaling the personality cult
of joseph stalin
he did so by presenting himself as the
personification of russian strength and
power
he reached into russia's past to
resurrect the ghosts of an earlier era
real or imagined
of stability security power and prestige
and he promised to return russia to the
summit
more broadly concepts of russian
nationality and defensiveness
reemerged on levels not seen since the
reigns of tsar's alexander iii and
nicholas ii
in the late 1800s and early 1900s
these coalesced in russia's 21st century
annexation of crimea
and its meddling in ukraine
in his own defense
putin argues that the west throughout
history
is
constantly trying to sweep russia into a
corner
putin has gone so far as to revive the
idea of a russian nation that's not
coterminous with existing political
borders
that's to say
he seems to believe that russia and its
leaders have a blank check on which to
draw to defend the interests of russians
even beyond its territorial borders
putin also revived the russian practices
and principles of strong authoritarian
leadership
a dynamic foreign policy
and a celebration of traditional russian
ideals
in a manner strikingly reminiscent of
past rulers like yvonne the terrible
during the 16th century catherine the
great in the 18th century
and of course joseph stalin
putin also propelled a revival of the
russian orthodox church including its
precepts of faith loyalty to the
hierarchy and national identity
and an appreciation for russia's
historical past extending beyond the
bolshevik revolution
these cultural currents facilitated the
rebuilding of great historical
structures like the cathedral of christ
the savior in moscow and an appreciation
for great literary figures including
alexander pushkin and leo tolstoy
but putin also inspired the persecution
of groups who didn't conform to state
prescribed
ideals
this includes the harassment sometimes
deadly of journalists who challenged his
status quo
the political and cultural renaissance
of russia under putin also led to
renewed popular fondness for
larger than life leaders like yvonne the
terrible peter the great
and stalin again
as you can see
the romanov czars may be long dead and
buried
the soviet union may be gone for good
but beliefs rooted in russia's long
history
and its rich culture
these endure